so this idea that the Saints have that
the more we Focus On Christ the more we
are moving towards Christ the more we
have to Humble ourselves more we have to
sacrifice ourselves and lower ourselves
because we recognize how flawed we are
how sinful we are in comparison right
and maybe to an external Observer it
would seem like we're becoming
Sanctified various Saints would say like
at the end of their life you know oh I
haven't even begun to repent so these
kind of inversions of of that this like
a simultaneous movement toward God and
the sense of moving away because we're
just so hate to say repugnant because of
our sins but it's our perception of that
it's not saying anything about God's
perception of us it's only speaking
about our perception of ourselves when
we start to really know ourselves in
relationship to
[Music]
Christ this is johathan Pedro welcome to
the symbolic
world
[Applause]
so hello everyone I have the great joy
to be here with Father Joseph Lucas
Father Joseph is the priest and pastor
at Christ the Savior Cathedral the OCA
cathedral in Florida uh he's also become
a good friend and he is the editor of
the rule of Faith Journal that you can
look up on Amazon it is an orthodox
Journal of theology but here I have them
here with me today because we had
amazing discussions when I was there he
has published his own thesis on the
question of sacrifice in St seral of
Alexandria I am lucky to have a copy of
it here and I thought that it would be
really wonderful to explore that with
him now and look at how the church
fathers obviously especially St serel
sees the question of sacrifice in the
Old Testament in the New Testament how
Christ transforms the question of
sacrifice and and just in general the
Insight that he provides and so Father
Joseph thanks for coming with us thank
you for inviting me and so when we
talked you said you had watched I think
even one of my videos and you thought
there was some interesting connections
to make with the manner in which St
seral presents the question of sacrifice
so maybe you can start us there and tell
us what it is that you think what
Insight you think that he
provides well I think for one thing it's
it's great because uh St serel really
had a he Focus his career I would say he
focused his career on trying to
understand the Old Testament and how the
New Testament is the fulfill of the Old
Testament and because sacrifice is such
an important part of the uh of the law
he had to deal with it a lot and it
comes up frequently throughout his
writing so he gives you know a very deep
interpretation of it but uh but it's
also important I think to understand it
as part of his overall biblical
interpretation like what he's trying to
do with the law how he's trying to bring
the law into uh you know into the church
in a way that that can be understood
properly and uh and so sacrifice I think
is at the root of that and so what does
he think sacrifice is
for well uh the very first uh reference
if you go sort of chronologically
Through the Bible the first sacrifices
can and Abel and uh he mentions it two
places so he has his commentary on the
Pento so he mentions you know he goes
into it there and then he also brings it
up again in his commentary on John which
is much later in his
career and between the two of them We
Come Away with a few uh a few ideas and
the first one I think think that's
that's really important is the idea that
sacrifice is innate in human nature
because there's no commandment God
doesn't tell can and abble go sacrifice
he never says you know here's how you do
it they just spontaneously do it there's
lots of ways you could come at that you
could say well there's other things not
written in in you know in the text that
would be one way of looking at it but St
sio approaches it that that there's this
natural desire for humans to want to
offer to God something to be to to
sacrifice to God he doesn't flesh that
out uh until a little bit later what
that ultimate sacrifice should be but in
that context he said it's just something
natural and so because one of them was a
shepherd and one was a farmer they just
took from what what gifts they had and
naturally wanted to give something to
God okay and uh when I when I first read
that it struck me because uh you know
that kind of ties in with say like a an
anthropological or perennial idea of the
of of the fact that sacrifices is in
every single culture throughout the
world right that innate desire is there
people want to do something uh for
whatever it is the numinous the
supernatural you know there's there's
whatever they perceive God to be uh they
want to make
offerings and uh and so the very first
offering that's recorded then in the
scripture of Cain and Abel is about that
innate desire and then how God responds
to that desire the right way to do it
and the wrong way to do it so so Abel's
the right way to do it it kan's the
wrong way to do it so that's kind of
where it starts out so for sure at the
outset it's important to notice that
stal doesn't see the sacrifice of Cain
and Abel as in any way a propitiatory
sacrifice he doesn't see it as something
that is like kind of sacrifice for our
sins the way that a lot of people think
sacrifice is only is only
for right I think well a good point
would be to to Define what we mean by
propitiation so if we mean propitiation
in the sense of just it's pleasing to
God be an acceptable definition uh
father Steven D and I just he was here
last week and we had a long talk about
that and and the fact that it can be
used in that way right but the problem
is is that it came to me in the west uh
assuaging or removing anger that God has
right so it's like so that's kind of a
pagan definition and definitely you
won't find that Pagan definition um in
St serel uh and later on when he starts
talking about the law that's when we get
into how he defines it and and and
probably the word I use a lot is
experation in English because it has the
it clearly connects to what what St s's
trying to do but definitely not with the
King and abble sacrifice there's no
sense of of God being upset with them
and they need to to to you know somehow
turn God's face back towards them or
something like that you get them to be
in commune with God it's just a It's s
serial sees it as a natural desire to
want to offer to God um to be in
relationship with God in some way yeah
so it's it's kind of yeah it it's some
it's like to give back to God or to
offer back with that which has been
received and so I mean this is a I don't
maybe he doesn't but what does he see as
Cain's Miss offering because in the text
it's very vague it just says basically
God doesn't accepted does he does he
talk about that well the subagent gives
us a little clue and he he hones in on
the because the subagent says you did
not rightly
divided okay uh so so he picks up on
that you know so what does it mean did
not rightly divided what means he he
offered uh The Leftovers basically is
how you know to paraphrase them like
what so you have offer the best part
exactly right he didn't take the very
best and offer to God he took what he
already didn't want interesting that
would that would also connect it in some
ways to the the the classic story of the
the sacrifice of Prometheus like in the
Greek myth where Prometheus is supposed
to like the people are supposed to offer
the meat but then he offers the bones
and just hides it with the skin so that
you they trick the gods basically yeah
so that so so it's about disposition
from the beginning and that's kind of
that's another theme that uh runs
throughout St serial's commentary in the
Old Testament uh this idea about the
right disposition when you offer what
does it mean so there's an inter there's
an internalization you know it's it's
what's coming out of the heart that's
being exhibited through the external
action you know through the sacrifice
itself but I didn't know that about that
in the septu agent there's a hint about
why it is that he the sacrifice and
that's interesting because I mean that's
that's a that's one of the most I mean
setan is one of the most ancient
testimonies of biblical interpretation
we have in the in the translation it's
like this is how we translated it it
means that this is how we see it so
that's a that's fascinating um and so
then so then after that I guess seriel
kind of moves into the story of
sacrifice and so how does he come from
this this early sacrifices up to Christ
like how does he see that
relationship well it's the way he he uh
approaches the law in particular is that
um everything in the law so this is this
is part of I think we have to look at
how he uh how he interprets the
scripture what his exod Jesus method is
and um the first well I would say you
know the experts disagree on this but I
I take this side is that his earliest
work is called on worship in spirit and
truth that's the you know the phrase
from St John's gospel and um it there's
a debate whether that was first or
whether he wrote his commentary in the
pentat first but it seems that that
would make more sense he wrote on
worship in spirit and Truth first
because he lays out how he's going to
interpret the scriptures and it seems
that he followed like throughout his
career he started with then he went on
to the pentti and he kind of moved in
chronological order through the
scriptures and and got to the gospels
and Epistles later in his career and why
that's important is because uh he starts
out his book on worship in spirit and
Truth with how do we interpret the law
and how does it relate to the New
Testament and he has this uh he has this
probably imaginary interocitor that he's
talking with and and and this uh this
guy is is walking along with a copy of
the gospels and you know this perfect
setup you know he says uh oh uh you know
sirel how how do we reconcile these two
things and he quotes First Matthew when
it says uh when Christ says that not you
know he didn't come to abolish the law
but to fulfill it how do we reconcile
that with where he says in the Gospel of
John uh that we're going to worship in
spirit and truth it seems that we he's
he's doing away with the law and then St
serel says the answer is in St Paul it's
the transition from the letter to the
spirit and then he kind of the rest of
that text he's kind of unpacking what
that looks like and applying it in a
kind of a u almost looking at like The
metan Narrative of scripture like or
what what St Nathan called the scope of
scripture which like you know the the
sort of Arc of uh story from Genesis all
the way to Revelation and um and he goes
through and he shows how the two things
relate and he has some uh some pretty
strong things to say about uh about the
law like he he picks up on what St Paul
says when the law is a type and a shadow
uh and so he says the law is a type and
a shadow and the formation of a piety
that is still in travail and has the
beauty of Truth hidden within itself and
he says the that the law was imperfect
only because they weren't ready to
interpret it through Christ so there's
this transition that happens where where
the law had its purpose but it could
never be it could never do what it was
meant to do he says that very clearly
it's never able to do what it was meant
to do until the Fulfillment of the law
came Christ and then through the lens of
Christ we understand it in a uh in a in
a anagogical or elevated way and so
that's kind of his starting point so
then he applies that to
sacrifice um all the
sacrifices are in some way pointing to
some aspect of what Christ was coming to
do uh and so that's that's kind of the
way he looks at it all the way through
is he takes these very sacrifices and he
reinterprets them and says this is how
it pertains to Christ or this is how it
pertains to the church you know sort of
this uh uh type and anti-type you know U
relationship throughout all the
sacrifices so can you give us some
examples of what like let's say let's
take one let's say the yam Kapur uh
sacrifice like does he does he talk does
he oh yeah deal with that because that's
I would love to hear what he how he says
about the two like the goat and the the
sacrifice the goat that's given to
Azazel like how does he cons reconcile
that with Christ yeah so so so as AEL
for him is is the devil that's
interesting because because uh but uh
but it's interesting that he says it's
not offered to the devil it's not
offered to the devil uh you know
essentially he says that that that would
be a myth he said to say that it was
offered as as AEL as the devil would be
a myth but the idea is that is that uh
so he he starts out with saying that
that the the symbolism of the Two Goats
they have to be absolutely
identical and the reason is is because
they're just two aspects of the same
offering just two two different aspects
of the same offering the first one
represents uh the the blood of the goat
taken into the temple represents
purification or experation so it shows
the fact that Christ would come to die
and through him we are we are purified
of sin okay so that's the first the
meaning of the first half the second
half um he does talk about Christ
carrying sin away okay connects it to
the Ascension uhuh so the idea is that
Christ going off into the desert land
where where AEL is where the devil is is
him going hering Hades and then
ascending up rising up and then
ascending up into the heavens uh and
then he calls it the untrodden land
Beyond is Paradise right he goes up to
be enthroned in the heavens and so he he
sees it in a very different way so
basically the two gos represent the
crucifixion resurrection and Ascension
you know that's kind of what together
they mean they're all part of the same
offering but different aspects of the
same of so he sees the goat that's cast
Into the Wilderness as resurrection and
Ascension yes huh yeah now he doesn't
now he he says that he does tie in at
one point and say that uh that
definitely he carries away our sins yeah
so I can imagine like the hering of
Hades that makes a lot of sense to think
of that you in the sense that he takes
the sins and and and he kind of goes
into it goes into the world of death you
could say but it's interesting to think
of it as a as Ascension and and uh yeah
that that one's kind of surprising it's
a surprising interpretation um let me
see if I find a quote right here he says
he Likens the himself to the scapegoat
in order to be sacrificed for sin so in
some sense he connects himself to sin
but then he says for he arose and
departed to the untrodden land meaning
into the heavens in some way carrying
our sins to the City on high to present
himself before the father on our
behalf so it's a it's a it's a weird
connection of all of us taking the sins
on carrying them away but then ascending
up and and and then he'll connect a
little bit later to the idea of him
being the the high priest mediator so he
carries them up to offer them up before
the father as as our mediator to be
purged of these sins in the heaven so
it's it's in a sense still connected
experation yeah but it's it's unusual
how he connects it to the resurrection
and the Ascension
but he he uses that same theme a couple
different ways with yam so he he says
the untrodden land so he's he's
connecting in some ways the paradise
with a Strange Land or a land that we
don't know like as if the Paradise in
some ways is a using the image of
Wilderness for Paradise like that to me
that's weird like that's a surprise I
have to say yeah it's it's it's it's
unusual it's uh it's not what I expected
because you know when you when you first
do a cursory reading of like the fathers
uh when you're trying to try come up
with a hypothesis
you know four thesis to examine the text
that's not what I would have come up
with initially and then when I you know
of course you read the text to let the
text teach you and then you get to these
things you're like okay he's he's coming
at this from a very different
perspective than I thought yeah but it's
I mean it's it's interesting definitely
and so so does he still have this idea
also of the offering to God like that
the crucifixion is an offering in the
sense of the can and aable sacrifice
does he does he talk about that a little
bit so he's he's fine with saying that
the offering was made towards the father
all right so this is before because it's
not until the about the 10th Century
that they work out this whole idea that
that that the the son is also the re
receiver but he does mention elsewhere
that the son as God also receives the
offering so he kind of presages that a
bit by about five centuries you know
which gets worked out later on in a in a
local Council in Constantinople where
they say that that the son is also the
receiver along with the father and
spirit so he does say that so on one on
one hand yes it's it's the it's the son
in his human nature so this is this is
something that would be controversial to
maybe uh some people who think that
seral is kind of a like an actual
monophysite in some way has a definite
idea of the distinction of the two
natures and so Christ's mediation is
really in his human nature right or
through his human nature so so through
his human nature he's offering himself
up to the father but as you know as God
himself with the father he's also
receiving that offering so he does
mention that as well so there's this
kind of connection there um but uh but
one of the things he's very clear about
is that there's no point in which the in
which the father somehow is disconnected
from him in this offering yeah that's
important like that that on that because
this is something we've seen recently uh
this idea that when Christ says you know
why have you abandoned me that God did
abandon him this is something that I
think Martin Luther ends up saying
explicitly that that that God abandoned
Christ in that moment on the cross but
sir St seral uh does not go in that
direction No in fact I we don't have any
idea who he's responding to at least I
haven't I I don't know and I haven't
found any other researchers who who have
uh looked at this but he's responding to
somebody when he says that uh you know
there's some there's some who would say
that the father looked away from the
cross when the son offered himself and
he goes at lyns to say why this is a
ridiculous idea as he said first of all
you know first of all there's there's
two reasons one is that he is with one
nature with the father and that's that's
obviously you know on a theological
level but then he says just on a very
practical level he said why would the
father look away from that which he
desired you know this this offering was
the will of the father and the son and
that which is most honorable why would
he look away from something so honorable
as the self-offering of his son so
there's this idea that you know there's
nothing there's nothing tainted in the
in the in the offering of Christ this is
his this is what was meant to be and and
the father would never would never
distance himself from that offering he's
a part of it in the fact in two ways the
fact that he's at at one with the son in
nature and also that uh and that he and
the son both desire this they have a
common will that they desire this thing
to happen and there's no sense of of
even in his human nature because that's
the one thing s does even though he he
definitely makes clear that there are
these you know there are two Natures a
human and divine uh nature um it's
always the Incarnate son acting I think
that's one of the important principles
of his theology is this it's it's the
one incarnate Lord acting you know and
so therefore you cannot even though it's
through his human nature that he is the
high priest can't divide it yeah he's
not yeah you can't divide it in any way
so how does he I mean maybe you you
don't have an answer for this but how
does he interpret that phrase you know
when Christ cries out to his
father uh so he he has essentially laid
out throughout this is more so not so
much in his exegesis more so in his U uh
his theological writings especially in
response to
noorus uh he makes clear that all the
things that Christ Christ went through
uh he did it not because he needed for
his own for his own sake but in order to
transform it for our sake so for example
uh the The Garden of Gethsemane was very
important for him yeah Garden of Geth is
a point where uh one of the blameless
passions one of the things that human
beings all suffer through you know even
if they're if even if they were
perfected would be the fear of death
because it's unnatural for us to really
die we want to to live we have a sense
of Eternity and um the fear of death is
real and that humans have to face this
and so in the guardian gemi he takes on
the uh the human fear of death in its
fullness in order to transform it for us
he says and does the same because he
accepts finally that's always what
people have to understand is that
although he goes through that anguish
then ultimately he accepts he he says
yes to the to to what is going to happen
right yeah he always uh St s always uh
emphasizes the idea this a voluntary
offering it has to voluntary it has to
be Christ doing this fully taking it on
active in every single part of it in
order to transform it for human nature
going forward yeah yeah there there's in
the garden of gsem there's so many
mysteries about that because one of the
things that I think is going on in the
Garden of Gethsemane is that
we're actually facing we're actually
seeing Christ in the garden about to eat
the fruit of the knowledge of Good and
Evil but he he doesn't want it right
that's the difference between him and
Adam he actually knows that if you eat
of that fruit you will die and he says
no if if I can be spared the fruit if I
can be spared this cup then then then
then but if that's your will then I'll
do it and so it's like God gives him the
fruit and now he takes it and dies but
then that is the image of his of his
being God like it's you could say that
it's his deification he's already God
but like it's his moment where he does
in fact manifest fully that he he is
like God by eating the fruit right well
it's it's it's a it's a it's a you know
the self- Ting keeps happening
throughout his entire Earthly life you
know it's not just it's not just that he
he poured himself out in the conception
in the theotokos his womb it's not
that's not the only moment in which he
he becomes humble and enters into the
you know the status of a of a slave
there's an
ongoing uh you know self-emptying
throughout his life all the way up to
the Cross ge's part of that that
progress and then on the cross when he's
saying you know my Lord my Lord why why
have you forsaken me he's taking on the
the he's taking on that the the the
human sense of separation of dejection
of you know and this is Again part of
him accepting all the blameless passions
and you know because those are things we
don't have control over right we it's
just like hunger and thirst and all the
other things he's taken on he has to
ultimately take on the fear of death the
fear of separation from God and then
death itself is the final foe he has to
take on you know in his uh that he
overturns through the resurrection and
and you know I know I know father
Stephen D young in part and others have
pointed out that in that moment where he
calls out and and and ask God ask his
father why he abandoned him there's also
a prophecy happening while he s saying
that because he's quoting from a Psalm
in which at the end of the psalm God
raises up you know David out of the pit
and so it's like he's actually so he's
saying like you said he's purifying it
he's like he's like I'm gonna I'm going
through this truly but there is a secret
prophecy hidden in what he's doing which
is that God will raise him up in the in
the in the end it's very powerful and
and it's always uh s s uses the uh the
phrase you know for our sakes all the
time right so idea I like to think of it
this is uh if you remember back in the
maybe late 80s and 90s I don't know if
you had this in Canada but we had the
oxy clean commercials when they first
came out and you had the tank of
oxyclean you know the white powder
thrown in the water and they Stir It Up
and uh and they had this immensely dirty
cloth or something and they they dip it
into the oxylean and they make a point
of saying instead of the oxylean looking
dirty the cloth comes out white you know
and so this is this is my analogy to try
to try to put a uh put forward
exactly what St s was explaining right
so so he's like this oxyclean right so
sin and and and these things are trying
to you know to attack him uh and in his
human nature he instead of him being
affected Anyway by the sin he doesn't
that's why St serel points out you know
that Paul says that he's without sin
he's like us in all ways but he's he's
without sin is that When sin tries to
tries to attack him or any of the the
blameless Tred to affect him instead of
him being affected there's an immediate
reversal for the sake of human nature at
large right so he reverses it or or
repels it in a sense and because he's of
one nature with us according to his
Humanity um we share in the benefits of
that in a potential right we potentially
share in the benefits of that when we by
faith are united to Christ we we are
given that power to repel the sin to not
be affected by it uh so it's part of his
it's part of his overall idea of how
we're saved how we're transformed uh
it's all rooted in how he you know how
he uh responds to these
things and and so what it's interesting
what kind of comes to mind in terms of
what uh the way that he presents
sacrifice is that it seems like if the
sacrifice of Cain and Abel at the outset
is natural in the sense that it's
something that is in us to want to give
up to God then it wouldn't if that's how
he sees the origin of sacrifice then it
makes sense that would move towards the
idea of self-sacrifice right where
ultimately you realize that the ultimate
sacrifice is the giving of of oneself
and so maybe you can talk a little bit
about his ideas on that and how Christ
brings us into that that that that
difference so the first thing is that is
that the law um was a way that to
channel the innate desire that's the
first thing right so so people have this
innate desire like K and Abel and so all
of human kind was you know in some way
making offerings and uh and reaching out
to what they understood God to be but in
the Revelation that God gives the
beginning with Moses and and forward
he's basically channeling that he's
basically uh or giving order to it
arranging it but he's doing it the one
of the things that St s was very clear
about is that none of it was necessary
right there was no God's God is without
necessity he doesn't need any he doesn't
need meat offerings he doesn't need
anything right there's which is said
which is said in like it says that in
scripture and that's really important to
remember that right exactly I mean it's
especially in the prophets you know it's
all through like Isaiah and Ezekiel and
things like that and he and he does one
of the things I focused on in my in my
thesis was also on the the the prophets
you know how he U sees that in the
prophets so so none these let me just
say one last thing because that's really
important because because if we believe
that then we understand that the idea of
the trade sacrifice like the of the
simple trade of like you know or or also
the idea that God God needs sacrifice in
order in order to forgive our sins or
some kind of weird idea that this is
necessary in from the point of view of
God for this to happen in order like as
if there's this like weird rule that you
know well now you've sinned so now
you're impure so you got to kill these
things so that God will God will uh that
you can have access to God again like
that is not
nowhere this type of thinking there's no
quid proquo yeah in the offerings yeah
there there's a sense that God doesn't
need it um and and so he does two things
so for one thing he he he makes it clear
that that uh he's going to organize and
and sort of Channel this
desire uh entirely to prepare people for
his coming and the only necessary
offering of himself he's the necessary
offering to accomplish what he desires
to do which is to save Humanity to uh
overcome death for us and things like
that so that's that that is what he
would say would be a necessary offering
in the way that that God wants to to
help mankind so he basically establishes
or channels this this uh Old Testament
offering system in order to point
everything towards Christ so everything
is pedagogical he takes up that that
idea from St Paul that the law is is a
is a tutor or pedagogue and so it's all
pedagogical or or symbolic to point
towards the one true offering of Christ
and then he can then he can go through
and and apply the spirit of the law
which the spirit of law is the intent so
so what's the true intent and he go he
presses this really really far because
he essentially says that uh that the Old
Testament law really had at some points
he says it wasn't efficacious in any way
right there's nothing it could actually
do there's a couple points where he
concedes a little bit and says that so
long as the uh as long as the Israelites
were doing it with the right intention
their faith had some efficacy right
there was something they were gaining
from being faithful and obedient to God
but that it couldn't actually do
anything because it wasn't just a like a
mechanical system like obviously that
that's ridiculous to think that it that
anyways right well that's that's why
that's why it gets uh condemned by the
prophets the prophets say look you think
it's an automatic thing it's all about
your intention about you're acting in
faith you're doing this in obedience and
faith and love towards God when you do
it in the right way then God is somehow
blessing you that's what St serial is
basically saying God is God will bless
you and response uh because you're doing
it out of Faith so he's channeling this
desire for sacrifice and if they do it
the right way with the right intent like
like AEL with the right with the right
heart um then God will respond back with
blessings for them okay yeah and let me
just say I just want to say the people
for the people watching and to
understand how this is organically true
in anything that has to do with any type
of relationship that you engage with
others whether it's hierarchical or
whether it's it's it's across levels is
that you know it if you it's not just
like okay so shake the person's hand you
know do this and that and if you do all
these things then you'll be in a right
relationship with others like we all
know that's nonsense like that's not
true of course we have to shake the
other person's hands of course we have
to we have to be polite we have to do
all these things that are kind of like
rules but if they're not done with the
right intention of of entering into
communion with the person then we know
that we could do all the right things
and and then we would find ourselves in
disharmony with others and so it's it's
as true for family meal for how you
relate to your children to your parents
to your to your spouse as it is for how
we also relate to God so it doesn't mean
that we completely remove the the
rituals the rituals are there to embody
the intention but without the intention
then the rituals ultimately can become
can become pernicious even you know it's
like if you shake someone's hand and you
you know you give them that look like
you know it's like I actually hate you
uh then the handshake is n you know yeah
yeah symbol plus intention I think
that's that's a good way to say what
what St c um how he defines it you know
you have to have the the meaning is
there but the meaning has to be backed
up by the right disposition but but
here's what he says though this is so
it's this idea that that the antitype
Christ is the only one who
uh uh imbus meaning to anything that
happened any of the types right the type
only only exists for the sake of the
antitype and so uh so for example he
says uh uh he says though the law of old
was not sufficient to help those in
olden times the Myster mystery of Christ
was outlined in it but with the coming
of Christ's purification by a type then
of necessity fell in obeyence since the
reality was now present and then he goes
on to say that uh you know that the real
reason that there was any kind of um you
know efficacy in the Old Testament
sacrificial system was because already
Christ was there in it yeah and now that
Christ has come it falls away and it
sounds like some of the wording he uses
I don't know if have you ever read uho
Sardis St Meo Sardis is uh this is a
great if uh if you have time to get it
sometime I know it's in the St vlad's
popular patristic series it's on PCA
it's the sermon that St Malo Sardis gave
in the second
century probably like on the eve of PCA
it's like it's like a a poetic sermon
that he gave and there's sections of it
that are quoted later on our apostal
hymnography so it actually got picked up
in the church and it's uh many scholars
think that he was a Jew who converted to
Christianity and became the bishop of
Sardis and so St molo I'll read this
little section of St Malo it's very
similar to what uh St s was writing a
couple centuries later he says this is
about the Passover and the blood of
Christ he says tell me oh Angel this is
the Angel of Death At what were you
turned away at the sacrifice of the
sheep or the life of the Lord at the
death of the sheep or the type of the
the Lord at the blood of the sheep or of
the spirit of the Lord clearly you were
turned away because you saw the mystery
of the Lord taking place in the Sheep
the life of the Lord in the sacrifice of
the sheep the type of the Lord in the
death of the sheep for this reason you
did not strike Israel but it was Egypt
alone that you made childless so it's
like the angel of death comes and he
already sees the mystery of the Lamb of
God who comes to take away the sins of
the world and he's turned away by that
very similar to what in fact i' like to
write an article at one point seeing if
there any connection if St s had any
access to St Mito because there's this
sense in in St C that you know that that
everything any any kind of response
positive response God had to Israel in
the Mosaic system was because he saw
that they were fulfilling what would
would ultimately point to Christ right
Christ is the one giving it power uh in
some way he says otherwise uh it would
become ineffectual if they did not if it
was not connected directly to
Christ and so then how does St Sero or
does he connect this ultimately with the
Christian Life that is to to show that
our life is a Living Sacrifice right
these these phrases that we say in in
our in our lurgical practice that or
that we see that that we are meant to
give ourselves ultimately that that is
what all of this is leading to in terms
of our own practice Yeah that's actually
that's I would say that's probably what
everything is about um for him because
he says you know so the sacrificial
system points to Christ
and then Christ accomplishes what he
needs to accomplish and so what is the
spirit of the law now the spirit of the
law now is to see how we become Christ
in in our self-offering so so basically
he sets up this idea that we have to
voluntarily die and then he connects
that to this idea of picking up our
cross each day and following after
Christ every day is like a like a
spiritual death or or our own
self-emptying uh for the sake of God and
um and this kind of uh sets up an entire
way of looking at the world you know
this this idea that the Christian is the
one who's constantly sacrificing
himself um yeah it's interesting I I I
tried to uh you know when I was when I
was completing the dissertation I spent
a couple years just reading all the
literature and sacrifice I could
possibly find and so I had to read I had
to read like you know you name it Gustaf
Island all these different ones I read
everyone who talked about different
aspects of of sacrifice and some of them
Christian some non-Christian uh
anthropological studies and I came to uh
Rene Gerard and uh and I was trying to
see in what ways like his scapegoat uh
you know idea um you know there's a
sense that I I saw that there's some
some parallels between his idea of the
scapegoat and how he says that Christ
ultimately fulfills that he becomes one
who takes on everything you know but uh
it was a little it still a little bit
too Protestant for me you know well it's
not just that it's that it's that Gerard
misses is another aspect of sacrifice we
and so if you take the yam kipur
sacrifice for example it's like there
are two sacrifices my friend there's one
that is out to the Wilderness and
there's one that's offered up and the
sacrifice that's offered up is not the
same is not a Christ brings them
together and in a very very sh mind
shattering way but they're not the same
and so you know it's like when for
example like the pouring out of
Libations and all of these types of
behaviors that the Ancients said cannot
be reduced to scape Co sacrifices so
Gerard is as if Gerard gets half of the
story right but he's missing an entire
half of the story which makes his theory
in my opinion insufficient and means
that it's difficult for him to reach
this conclusion so his tendency will be
to say that Christ has abolished
sacrifice and now there's no more
sacrifice now there's no more sacred
there's actually no more sacred anymore
whereas the Christian the true Christian
position is to say Christ has shown how
all of this has to to become
internalized and that we can be take the
sins of others to some extent even that
we can sacrifice ourselves that we can
become the scapegoats in many ways that
that is a healing and that it and that
internalized process now is the way that
we live and it's actually the way that
it's actually our morality is based on
that implicitly or explicitly is based
on that image of what the S of what
sacrifice is I think well in the uh the
20th century in St silon the athonite
uh he has this idea that uh you know the
ultimate goal is for us to all become
Adam and a sense and take on the sins of
of the world in a sense right to be like
Christ is to be able to become a
scapegoat ourselves to become you know
the Passover offering ourselves to the
entire all the symbolism of the the Old
Testament sacrificial system capitulated
in Christ we have to imitate that we
have to take that on in some way and
live a life of self- offering of
constant sacrifice um and uh it's
unbearable like it's I hate every moment
of what you just said like I just hate
that I don't want to do that but I can
see in the story like if you look at
some of the stories of the Saints you
have very powerful images especially in
the monastic stories of monks who do
exactly that who actually take on blame
of things they did not do towards the
salvation of others and in the in the in
when people see the monk taking the
blame for their sins onto themselves you
know they're transformed in ways that
approach or that just scolding or
whatever punishment would never be able
to accomplish it's it's some of these
stories are pretty amazing well that if
I if I could Branch off into just
something else for one second it it ties
in with so I've been my my kind of whole
project over the last 20 years has been
uh looking at you know Su triology how
how salvation Works through the the
father's interpretation of the Bible and
before I started working on sacrifice
and expiation I looked at justification
and uh and so I have a little I put out
a little book back in 2010 um based on
my research on that and it was uh
focusing on the desert fathers and so
the desert fathers were picking up on
the Gospel of Luke where in the Gospel
of Luke in the the parable of the uh of
the Publican and the Pharisee the uh the
Publican basically by by accepting all
blame he descends down and the uh and
he's the one who's Vindicated or
justified by God because he descends
down by taking on all blame and God's
the one who vindicates and lifts him
right he exalts him and then the
Pharisee he exalts himself and God
lowers him right he brings him down uh
and and condemns him and of course the
words the word in Greek for uh to
justify or vindicate
Theo um it's opposite as K which means
to condemn those two words are used in
the parable so it's the opposite of to
vindicate right he gets condemned down
and and that gets picked up in Orthodoxy
in the the hymn for one of the one of
the troparia for that Sunday of the
Publican the Pharisee during Lent it
says for the you know for the Publican
exalted himself or lowered himself based
himself and he was exalted up and the uh
the Pharisee exalt himself and he was he
was abased you know he was brought down
low so we have this idea that that when
we take on the blame when we take on and
become that offering uh we allow God as
judge Christ as judge to be the one to
lift us up and exalt us you know he's
the one who takes us up to the to the
heights uh rather than uh ourselves you
know so it's kind of linked to this
that's why you see this this sort of
language throughout especially like the
aesthetical writings the neptic fathers
the desert fathers
yeah understanding that way makes so
much sense of so many Bible stories you
know even from the beginning from
Genesis you know and so you know you
that's how you can understand that what
God is asking of Adam you you know to
not raise himself up you know to not
himself take the fruit to not to not
pull himself up that that that what God
wanted for him was to for that God does
like that God was going to raise Adam up
and you see that in the in the scripture
Sometimes It's Tricky for people because
it's people might find it hard to see
that in the text because it's like well
you know it's a it's a bit tricky of St
Ephraim to say that God wanted to give
him the fruit doesn't say that in the
text you know but if you take the entire
scope of if you take the entire scope of
of scripture and you kind of see it
together you realize that it's there all
through like even the story of Solomon
when it's like God asks Solomon what
what he wants it's like I will give you
and then he says I want the knowledge of
Good and Evil and God is like good that
yes that's exactly what you should ask
for and I'm going to give it to you but
he doesn't he's not trying to take it
for himself so this weird moment when
Solomon shows us already that this was
there there in the whole narrative
scripture this idea that what is
received from above is different from
than what is taken for ourselves it's
the opposite in some ways and it and
we're lifted up when we when we abase
ourselves it's it seems contradictory
but once you kind of see the logic
you're like actually no that's really
how reality works yeah yeah it's it's so
it's it's so uh prevalent throughout all
of the U at least in the I'm not as
familiar with the Western lurgical
tradition but in the Eastern lurgical
tradition I mean this idea of humbling
yourself is is is just uh ubiquitous
it's everywhere I mean it's just I mean
all of all of Lent focuses on that right
all the the the hymns and the various
themes of the services is almost always
about how do we humble ourselves before
God repentance is of course part of
humbling which is so important during
the the fasting Seasons because
repentance is about admitting you know
that that we are against God and turning
back towards him and and and
reestablishing relationship because
we're in the wrong we take on the blame
and um and the more we take on the
blame uh you know we allow God to be God
because when Christ says that uh you
know that he says judge not lest you be
judged he's not talking about a lack of
discernment right because the same wordo
is the same word to judge or to discern
they're not two different words we
sometimes translate them differently but
they're the same word used in different
parts positively and negatively in the
New Testament what he's saying is is
don't usurp my position I am the Lord I
sit on the throne of judgment I hold the
keys you know uh to life and death don't
youer my position uh it's not your place
to determine you know the the outcome of
of you know human Affairs or of
individual humans um you have to humble
yourself and see yourself uh only in
comparison to me he says right and so
again in the desert fathers there's this
idea of uh you know it says uh you know
who is man that you know he's made a
little lower than the angels and they
take that and they say you know God
placed us down here you know in this in
this reality and you know this idea of
up and down right of above and below um
we we should only be looking up we
should only be we should we're down here
only looking up at the Lord and
comparing ourselves only to him and we
compare ourselves only to
Christ we can't really exalt ourselves
in any way you know in fact um um this
ties into uh like in Isaiah 6 when
Isaiah who's probably the holiest man of
his time right he's this incredible
prophet and he gets initiated into the
throne room of God he's there in
probably what St Paul would call the
third heaven or something like that and
uh and he says I I am undone I'm a man
of unclean lips so this idea that the
that the that the Saints have that the
more we Focus On Christ the more we are
moving towards Christ the more we have
to Humble ourselves more we have to
sacrifice ourselves and lower ourselves
because we recognize how how you know
how flawed we are how sinful we are uh
in comparison right that comparison it's
like it's like this weird inversion
where we're moving towards Christ and
maybe to an external Observer it would
seem like we're becoming Sanctified our
own perception of it we realize how much
further we're getting away from him
simultaneously so various various Saints
would say like at the end of their life
uh you know oh I haven't even begun to
repent you know or you know or I'm
afraid you know they're glowing with the
uncreated light and then and the people
there hear him talking and say you know
uh he says he's he's responding to the
demons I I don't have any hope you know
you know so these kind of inversions of
of that this like a simultaneous
movement toward God and the sense of
moving away because we're just so uh
hate to say repugnant you know uh
because of our sins but it's our
perception of that right it's not saying
anything about God's perception of us
it's only speaking about our perception
of ourselves when we start to really
know ourselves in relationship to
Christ you know and and the more we're
able to offer ourselves up freely to
Christ the more we move towards him but
the more we realize how much more work
we have to do in offering ourselves up
yeah yeah and you can see like you know
you can see how this
applies even at lower levels you know
when you
think you know when you think of the
problem of the politician you know the
problem of democracy for example which
is that you end up with like narcissists
you know because you have to you have to
fight so much to get it like you have to
do everything you know and basically to
get that position of power you have to
be willing to do anything lie do
whatever it takes just to get there
whereas what we really want is something
like a reluctant King like that's what
we would really want right someone who
we know is the best to be the king but
really he doesn't want to be the king
and we almost have to force like to say
no you're the king you know like all
these stories of of the ancient Bishops
you know they go get the the monk in the
cave and see say okay you're the the
bishop and you you would just run away
and bring it back no no like we know
that you're the bishop so that's what we
would want but it's a it's yeah it's
difficult
to yeah it it's it's at the one hand
impossible you know it just feels
impossible but on the other hand you
know that it it has to be that way and
that's the that's actually the best
image of reality right Father Joseph
this was amazing like thank you so much
for for for this conversation and uh and
uh and uh and yeah and I hope I see you
I think you're you said you're going to
come to the symbolic World Summit and so
people can will be able to meet you
there that's my plan I hopefully get up
there I mean it's not that far I mean
tarp and springs we call it uh Tarpon P
that's a Greek because it's it's
entirely Greek up there exactly it's
like the Greek capital of America I try
to get up there once every year or so
and uh my family and and walk around the
Sponge Docks and buy some Greek stuff
and bring it back to Miami so so
definitely looking forward to to to
seeing you again and uh thanks for your
Insight and thank you for your time
father
yeah